mes chers collègues c'est un honoré un
réel plaisir de pouvoir échanger
aujourd'hui avec Madame Emilie Aurélie
qui est médiatrice de l'Union européenne
je rappelle qu'au terme de l'article 42
de la Charte européenne des droits
fondamentaux tout citoyen de l'Union
ainsi que toute personne physique ou
morale résidant ou ayant son siège
statutaire dans un État membre a le
droit de saisir le Médiateur européen
en cas de mauvaise administration dans
l'action des institutions organes ou
organismes de l'Union à l'exclusion de
la Cour de justice de l'Union européenne
dans l'exercice de ses fonctions
juridictionnelles
et dans ce cadre madame la médiatrice
vous faites preuve d'un engagement sans
faille que nous saluons au service de
nos concitoyens
d'abord pour mieux leur faire comprendre
l'Union Européenne ainsi comme l'indique
votre rapport d'activité pour 2022 vous
avez aidé plus de 16000 citoyens
donnés 13313 conseils et traités 2238
nouvelles plaintes et ensuite pour
inciter l'Union européenne à devenir
plus transparente et exemplaire sur les
enjeux éthiques
j'ajoute que vous avez toujours été
attentif à répondre aux questionnements
du Sénat et nous vous en remercions vous
aviez ainsi déjà répondu à notre
invitation en mai 2020
je veux rappeler plusieurs priorités de
votre mission de sentinelle contre la
mauvaise administration
en premier lieu vous travaillez une
transparence accrue des institutions de
l'Union européenne dans ce domaine au
cours des derniers mois vous avez obtenu
plusieurs avancées telles que la
transmission de statistiques sensibles
sur les pollutions maritimes ou la
publication de documents de travail du
Conseil sur l'élaboration de la
réglementation européenne sur les
marchés numériques le DMA
en revanche le 14 juillet dernier de
l'an dernier vous émettiez publiquement
un signal d'alarme je reprends les
termes de votre communiqué de presse au
sujet du refus de la Commission
européenne de transmettre les
éventuelles textos qui auraient été
échangés par sa présidente avec le PDG
d'une société pharmaceutique en
l'occurrence Pfizer au sujet des vaccins
contre le covid-19 vous aviez ouvert une
enquête à ce sujet et émis des demandes
réitérer de communication de ces
documents en vain
ce dossier fait aujourd'hui l'objet de
deux plaintes l'une devant la justice
belge et l'autre devant le Tribunal de
l'Union européenne quelles leçons
tirez-vous de cette affaire
le dysfonctionnement aussi pointé semble
cependant d'une ampleur plus large que
cette seule affaire ainsi dans une
recommandation vous avez dénoncé les
retards systémiciens importants dans la
manière dont la Commission européenne
traite les demandes d'accès du public
aux documents nous sommes donc
intéressés par votre analyse sur ce
point
en deuxième lieu je voudrais vous
interroger sur la pratique du
pantouflage de la Commission européenne
c'est-à-dire le recrutement de cadres
des administrations européennes voire de
commissaire européen qui régulent un
secteur par une entreprise de ce secteur
pratique qui a fait l'objet d'une
enquête de votre part quels sont ses
conséquences sur les décisions de
l'Union européenne et comment l'encadrer
plus strictement en troisième lieu je
veux saluer votre rôle de conseil au
Parlement européen qui tente de
renforcer ces procédures déontologiques
depuis les révélations du scandale
dénommée catargate
plusieurs parlementaires européens
anciens parlementaires aurait été payés
par le Qatar et le Maroc pour servir les
intérêts de ces pays dans les décisions
européennes ces révélations ont ravivé
la méfiance de nombreux citoyens à
l'égard des élus un plan en 14 points
était présenté par la présidente mezzola
en janvier dernier il propose en
particulier de mieux encadrer la
reconversion des anciens parlementaires
en représentant d'intérêt et prévoit une
plus grande transparence de l'activité
des députés européens et de leur réunion
ce plan qui n'est toujours pas mis en
place ou semble-t-il suffisant enfin la
Commission européenne un peu sous
contrainte il faut le dire à présenter
le 8 juin dernier un projet d'accord
inter-institutionnel afin d'instituer un
organe d'éthique européen soyons clairs
c'est une déception en effet cet organe
aurait compétence pour formuler des
lignes directrices et favoriser
l'échange de bonnes pratiques mais il ne
disposerait ni d'un pouvoir d'enquête ni
d'un pouvoir de sanction et son
fondement juridique sur un accord
inter-institutionnel ne semble pas de
nature à assurer l'indépendance de cet
organe à l'égard des institutions qu'il
est destiné à contrôler
chaque institution continuerait donc à
s'autoréguler dans le domaine éthique
dès le 6 juin dernier lors d'une
conférence abrute à Bruxelles vous aviez
estimé que la limitation de cette
autorégulation était l'une des
conditions du succès de la réforme c'est
pourquoi madame la médiatrice nous
souhaiterions avoir votre avis d'abord
cet organe d'éthique est-il nécessaire
si oui qu'elles doivent être ses
compétences et enfin un lien
institutionnel ne devrait-il pas être
prévu entre cet organe et votre fonction
je terminerai mon propos par le constat
de l'urgence de cette réforme éthique
européenne en effet en 2018 l'Union
européenne a fait le choix de mener une
politique dite de l'État de droit qui
permet à la Commission européenne par
exemple de conclure que la justice n'est
pas respectée dans tel État membre ou
qu'une réforme envisagée menace les
libertés dans tel autre or pour assumer
ce rôle encore faut-il être soi-même
exemplaire en matière d'éthique sinon le
risque est d'apparaître comme un
Tartuffe aux yeux des citoyens européens
qui s'exprimeront dans les urnes l'an
prochain nous allons nous-mêmes des
travaux sur ce sujet dans les mois à
venir je vous remercie pour répondre à
toutes ces questions mais aussi de votre
intervention plus généraliste je suppose
président
chers membres de la commission des
affaires étrangères bonjour de
Strasbourg ou le Parlement européen
organise à sa dernière session plénière
avant la pose estivale merci de cette
occasion d'expliquer le rôle de la
médiatrice de l'Union européenne qui
n'est pas toujours très connu en dehors
de Bruxelles
mais nous faisons comme vous l'avez dit
un travail très important ce rôle a été
créé par le traité de Maastricht en 1993
le la médiatrice est élu par le
Parlement européen et la Commission et
les États membres ne plaît aucun rôle
dans ce processus avant de avant mon
élection en 2013 j'ai été médiatrice de
la République d'Irlande et commissaire à
la liberté de l'information pendant 10
ans
je m'inquiète de mes devoirs de manière
complètement indépendante je prends mes
propres décisions lorsqu'il s'agit
d'ouvrir des enquêtes à la suite parfois
de plainte ou alors ce sont des enquêtes
de ma propre initiative quand tu as des
sujets systématiques le bureau du
médiateur est un pont direct entre les
citoyens de l'Union européenne et
l'administration de l'Union européenne
qui crée et met en place des lois et des
qui prend des décisions qui ont des
effets sur nos vies quotidiennes
donc ce sont des institutions qui sont
responsables de l'Institut de l'adoption
de plus de 250 actes législatives et
nous ne parlons que de l'année 2022 la
Commission le Conseil le Parlement mais
également la Banque centrale européenne
et environ 40 agences de réglementation
je reçois environ 2200 plaintes par an
de la part des citoyens des
organisations de la société civile ou
des entreprises et j'ouvre environ 400
en quête
en 2022 129 plaintes venaient de France
et j'ai ouvert 24 enquêtes elle
concernait des problématiques comme des
désaccords sur des contrats ou des
subventions de l'Union européenne à des
refus d'accès aux documents des
violations de droits fondamentaux
des désaccords concernant donc les 100
version européennes des relations de
droit constamment de droits fondamentaux
ou des soupçons de conflits d'intérêts
ou des manquements quant à la diligence
requise concernant les procédures pour
infraction de menées par la commission
mon objectif principal est de m'assurer
que les citoyens ont alors servi une
administration européenne transparente
et efficace pour faire cela je peux
utiliser mon droit de d'agir de ma
propre initiative pour lancer des
enquêtes ou demander des informations
aux institutions cela signifie que au
lieu d'attendre qu'un problème soit
porté à mon attention sous la forme
d'une plainte je peux agir de manière
proactive ouvrir une enquête ce qui est
particulièrement
utile lorsqu'il s'agit de s'attaquer à
des problèmes systématiques au sein de
des institutions européennes j'ai
utilisé ce pouvoir pour examiner la
transparence des crêpes des groupes
d'experts qui conseillent la commission
par exemple les réunions des ministres
des Finances de l'UE ou
l'agence de gestion des frontières de
l'uefontex pour s'assurer qu'elle
respectent ces obligations en matière de
droits fondamentaux plus récemment
j'ai réagi à des signalements de la
Commission de selon lesquelles en
fonctionnaire avait négocié un accord
aérien avec les le gouvernement qatari
et avait accepté des vols gratuits de la
part de Qatar Airways et en fait la
personne qui était responsable de la
vérification d'un conflit d'intérêt
était la même personne qui avait accepté
ses vols gratuits nous espérons que
l'information fournie par la commission
nous montrera de manière plus générale
comment elles gèrent les potentiels
conflits d'intérêts avec des voyages
officiels qui sont subventionnés par des
tiers et qu'elle mènera à une
amélioration des procédures et des
vérifications à l'avenir c'est un titre
c'est incident n'est qu'un exemple des
curieuses lacunes qui persistent au
cadre du au sein du cadre éthique de
l'UE plus de 20 ans après la démission
de la commission senteur à la suite d'un
scandale éthique majeur c'est lacunes
ont été encore plus exposées par le les
relations du cathargate qui a ébranlé le
Parlement européen l'année dernière
ce n'est que l'une des conséquences de
mon mandat le fait d'intervenir quand
les choses tournent mal ou lorsque les
procédures impartiales n'ont pas été
suivies lorsque les intérêts privés sont
privilégiés aux biens communs lorsque
les individus les citoyens n'ont pas
reçu les réparations qui leur sont
pourtant dues je voudrais dire cependant
que cela ne doit pas détourner notre
intention du travail incroyable et du
dévouement des fonctionnaires de l'Union
européenne qui souvent passent inaperçus
c'est pour cela que depuis 2017 j'ai
organisé un une cérémonie de récompenses
biennale pour la bonne administration
qui célèbre l'excellence et l'innovation
que l'on peut trouver partout au sein de
l'administration de l'Union européenne
cette année notre plus grand notre plus
grande récompense a été donné à l'unité
de coopération judiciaire de lieu your
ajust pour leur collaboration avec la
Cour pénale internationale qui a eu pour
résultat une série de directives afin
d'aider la société civile à documenter
les crimes de guerre et les crames les
crimes combien contre l'humanité pour
que cela c'est pour que ces documents
soient à la hauteur des examens
juridiques juridiques approfondie ce
n'est qu'un exemple parmi tant d'autres
qui montrent à quel point le travail
dans les institutions n'est pas glamour
que l'on travaille en coulisse mais que
cela représente les infrastructures
matérielles et matériels la base de
notre de notre finalité commune et dans
notre action collective dans ce contexte
nous avons notre mission aidé les
institutions européennes à faire face au
plus grand défi de notre époque par
exemple l'Union européenne récemment
s'est mis d'accord sur un fond de
relance de 700 milliards d'euros pour
aider les membres les États membres
après la pandémie
aujourd'hui nous négocions une loi pour
réguler les grandes entreprises
technologiques l'Union européenne s'est
fixée l'objectif de devenir carbone man
neutre d'ici 2050 un fond de défense
européen et devenu opérationnel en 2021
et grâce à la facilité européenne de
soutien à la paix l'Union européenne a
fourni des armes à l'Ukraine beaucoup de
ces grands domaines politiques ont des
conséquences surtout la planning voilà
pourquoi la planète voilà pourquoi à
Bruxelles c'est nous trouvons un grand
centre de lobbying pour ceux qui veulent
garder un oeil ou avoir une influence
sur les prises de diffusion par exemple
la guerre en Ukraine a eu des
conséquences sur l'approvisionnement en
carburant sur l'environnement sur la
sécurité toutes ces domaines façonnent
le monde de lobbying de Bruxelles voilà
pourquoi il faut absolument que les
règles en matière d'éthique et de
responsabilité de l'Union européenne
soit tout à fait respecter et évolue
avec le temps un bon exemple une un
nouveau sujet pour l'Union européenne
c'est l'enregistrement des conversations
téléphoniques des messages instantanés
qui concernent le travail il y a de plus
en plus de preuves qui nous montrent que
des décisions importantes prises par
Lyon fonctionnaires et des hommes
politiques sont faites par sur des
applications de messagerie instantanées
WhatsApp signaler Instagram etc
effectivement c'est
applications ont plusieurs avantages il
y a un côté informel elles sont rapides
cependant cela est un défi pour ceux qui
cherchent à s'assurer que le personnel
compétent est toujours tenu au courant
de ce qui se passe et cela permet
d'identifier le contenu réel la prise de
décision après coup et cela rend
également flou les frontières entre les
réseaux privés et professionnels
donc il y a une enquête de mon bureau
concernant la présidente de la
commission et ces messages avec faycer
cela a montré les enjeux et les
problématiques de ce nouveau phénomène
les messages qui ont été signalés n'ont
soit été pas sauvegardés soit considéré
comme n'étant pas concerné par les lois
de l'Union européenne sur la liberté de
l'information cela nous montre que le
cadre régulatoire au niveau de l'Union
européenne et internationale étant
danger et les potentiellement obsolètes
à cause de cette nouvelle réalité nous
avons fourni des orientations
officielles à l'administration de
l'Union européenne pour gérer ce genre
de problématique mais évidemment c'est
un paysage qui évolue rapidement
ces dernières années j'ai également
concentré mon attention sur le défi du
pantouflage donc entre le secteur privé
et le public sur la transparence des
activités de lobbying et sur la
transparence législative parce que c'est
c'est domaine sont au cœur des prises de
décision de l'Union européenne et sont
vitales lorsqu'il s'agit de la
responsabilisation de l'Union européenne
et de la démocratie les citoyens doivent
savoir comment les lois sont créées qui
ou quoi influencent les prises de
décision concernant ces lois
lorsqu'une entreprise privée choisie
toute particulièrement un représentant
de l'Union européenne venant d'un organe
de régulation particulier pour obtenir
des informations confidentielles qui est
essentielle pour cette
entreprise ou un ancien député européen
ou des commissaires influents avec un
bon carnet d'adresses
pour que ces représentants d'intérêts
privés et accès à ces informations et
bien cette influence est sollicitée de
manière légale mais souvent c'est
difficile à justifier pour les citoyens
ordinaires beaucoup de ces phénomènes ce
phénomènes sont bénins ces intentions
sont légitimes cependant il faut savoir
comment distinguer le Bénin d'une
néfaste avant que cela nuise ou alors
savoir sanctionner lorsque le mal a été
fait mon travail dans ce domaine
concerne principalement de l'influence
est-ce que la législation européenne est
influence d'une manière qui résulte en
une dilution de l'intérêt général est-ce
que la force de cette influence a pour
résultat une mauvaise gestion
des conflits d'intérêts un manque de
transparence un régime laxiste
concernant le pantouflage est-ce que les
règles mises en place sont suivies nous
avons lancé des enquêtes sur des
problèmes systémiques ou des cas
individuels de pantouflage avec le
banquier européenne d'investissement
l'Autorité bancaire européenne l'agence
de défense européenne est la Commission
européenne entre autres en partie en
résultat grâce à plutôt grâce à ses
examens publics il y a eu du progrès des
périodes de réflexion plus longues des
restrictions plus strictes concernant
les activités de lobbing et les
commissions et les activités des
commissaires plus de transparence
notamment
en ce qui concerne le secteur privé
cependant le progrès a été
progressive lent et les saisissant de
voir que les réformes significatives et
les innovations n'interviennent qu'après
des scandales et qu'après l'indignation
des citoyens plutôt d'être
le résultat d'une évaluation réfléchie
et lucide et risque menançants
l'intégrité des citoyens
voilà pourquoi les accusations selon
lesquelles des anciens actuellement
membres du Parlement ont été
ont été en lien avec le
Qatar
ont été donc voilà pourquoi ces
accusations sont extrêmement graves je
vous parle 7 mois après ce scandale qui
a suscité une attention toutefois toute
particulière sur la façon dont l'Union
européenne protège son intégrité et sa
crédibilité et évidemment ça légitimité
cela montre que il nous faut un cadre
éthique fort qui peut résister à ce que
le président metzola a décrit juste
après le Qatar gate des attaques contre
notre démocratie mais ce n'est pas aussi
simple que l'on pourrait le penser la ce
qui semble être une approche claire et
unie lors des premiers jours de la crise
a finalement été remplacé par
un débat complet sur la base légale de
certaines mesures sous couvertes
d'inquiétude concernant l'indépendance
du mandat des parlementaires et d'autres
thématiques ont été évoquées évoquées
concernant le monde politique les gars
l'administratif cela ralentit notre
réforme
donc nous parlons de systèmes éthique
concernant des problématiques éthiques
qui dépassent de loin la corruption du
cathargate
le catargate a montré à quel point ces
réformes fondamentales sont nécessaires
les réformes qui ne se limitent pas à
des règles supplémentaires ce qui est
nécessaire c'est une discussion pas
européenne sur les barrières à ces
réformes
ne pas parvenir à réformer le système de
l'intégrité de l'administration
européenne à des implications pour
l'intégrité du marché unique de l'espace
Schengen de l'intégrité de notre dette
collective et un impact sur nos
objectifs communs ce débat panneau
européen peut s'inspirer d'expérience et
de bonnes pratiques dans tous les États
membres qui sont eux aussi face à ce
défi de la protection d'intégrité des
systèmes politiques par exemple
une caractéristique de tout système
d'intégrer d'intégrité
apporte sur
le fait d'avoir un système qui permet de
contrôler les institutions il y a de
telles agences comme mon bureau l'Agence
européenne de lutte anti fraude le
parquet européen Cours des comptes
européennes
et trop souvent l'échelle européenne
nous voyons ces recommandations
constructives et informées
en silence alors que le Parlement
européen refuse parfois ce que des
enquêteurs ne luthentifs à ces locaux ce
qui avait espéré que des réformes
ambitieuses voient le jour
auront été déçus par la proposition de
la Commission européenne à mettre en
place un organe déontologique
inter-institutionnel le mois dernier il
n'y aura pas de nouvelles institutions
de nouveaux pouvoirs de nouvelles règles
plutôt cet organe visera à convenir de
normes communes pour ces 9 institutions
membres dont la Commission est par le
mot le Parlement européen et ce sera un
forum permanent pour les différentes
institutions et organes européennes pour
discuter de normes déontologiques et
pour demander des comptes les unes aux
autres en cas de mauvaise mise en oeuvre
tout cela est bienvenu et cette
progressivité la marque de fabrique des
réformes déontologiques européennes mais
nous sommes encore loin
déontologique indépendante demandée par
beaucoup beaucoup qui d'ailleurs
s'inspirent de la Haute Autorité
transparente de la vie publique
française c'est citoyens européens qui
ont connu des systèmes déontologiques
indépendants qui fonctionnent
vont remettre en question ce qui est
proposé ils vont en mettre en question
notamment la mesure dans laquelle cette
auto régulation va rester une
caractéristique du nouveau régime
renoncer ou en tout cas réformer de
façon significative l'autorégulation et
ce qui est nécessaire si l'on veut une
réforme crédible efficace mais quel que
soit le nouveau mécanisme en place la
nouvelle institution c'est la culture
qui détermine tout les institutions
européennes
parviennent à élaborer des règles très
facilement mais la réforme de la culture
et ce qui sera plus difficile à mettre
en oeuvre en tant que médiatrice
j'ai constaté que les administrations
les plus fortes les plus efficaces ne
sont pas celles qui ont le plus de
règles mais plutôt celles qui ont une
culture d'intégrité qui est pleinement
intégré
c'est ce que l'on obtient lorsque l'on
cultive un esprit déontologique
et que l'on respecte nos valeurs
les plus essentielles la fragilité de
l'autorité morale et la fragilité de nos
institutions démocratiques et quelque
chose dont nous avons malheureusement
trop conscience en ces temps difficiles
et regagner cette autorité est une tâche
laborieuse
en tant que européen nous avons su
trouver le courage moral nécessaire à de
nombreuses reprises face à des défis
encore plus considérables et j'ai bonne
confiance que en utilisant le même état
d'esprit et la même détermination nous
pourrons réparer le préjudice qui est
survenu au sein de nos institutions je
vous remercie
merci beaucoup madame la médiatrice de
toutes ces de toutes ces précisions et
on vous sent effectivement engagé dans
la mission alors je vais demander à mes
collègues s'ils ont des questions à
poser madame ma médiatrice Didier Marie
oui merci Madame etatrice pour vous
propose moi j'aurais juste une question
c'est de savoir de quels moyens vous
disposez
en termes de budget en termes d'effectif
pour mener les investigations qui sont
celles que vous avez évoquées
on prend peut-être une autre question
non
bon
allez-y madame je vous en prie
j'ai tendance à dire nous sommes un
petit bureau avec un mandat gigantesque
nous recevons nos moyens
de l'argent on est contribuables et nous
essayons d'utiliser ces fonds de façon
la plus efficace possible alors la
majorité des recommandations que nous
formulons sont acceptées mais ce qui est
critique dans notre travail
je le rappelle je peux prendre des
décisions sur les lancer ou non
d'enquêtes
qui est important c'est que je dois
pouvoir voir tous les documents
nécessaires
lorsqu'ils sont nécessaires et les
institutions européennes doivent me
transmettre ces documents je ne vais pas
nécessairement les publier mais je dois
pouvoir les utiliser lorsque je traite
telle ou tel compte
mon rapport
et bien il donne la garantie que l'effet
ont été réunis de façon indépendante et
ensuite
les institutions agence concernées
prennent les mesures nécessaires en
conséquence
difficile parfois de trouver des
solutions rapidement les solutions
peuvent prendre du temps avant de voir
le jour il peut y avoir des
recommandations
qui nécessitent quelques années de
travail parfois on parle comme je l'ai
dit d'un changement de culture donc
les recommandations
nous les formulons en sachant très bien
que cela va prendre du temps donc
nous avons les ressources nécessaires
nous avons augmenté le nombre
d'enquêteurs à notre disposition mais
lorsque je suis arrivé il y a 10 ans on
me demandait si j'avais besoin davantage
de ressources
j'ai dit je veux d'abord m'assurer que
ma stratégie fonctionne
que mon travail un impact réel que
l'efficacité est bien réelle et
maintenant nous je dois dire que nous
sommes beaucoup plus rapides qu'il y a
10 ans
et je crois qu'il faut que l'on
sentir de nos valeurs et que l'on fasse
preuve d'exemplarité merci
merci madame Martin Sidrac merci
président madame la médiatrice je
voulais vous remercier donc pour un
certain nombre d'éclaircissements que
vous avez partagé avec nous toutefois
j'avais une question parce que alors je
ne sais pas si c'est exactement le terme
que vous avez utilisé mais en tout cas
au niveau de la traduction
il a été question donc d'un certain
nombre de d'interactions qualifiés comme
Bénin au regard des désagréments que
cela pouvait produire dans le
fonctionnement des
instances alors je me posais simplement
la question pensez-vous malgré tout que
dès lors que nous avons ce genre de de
comportement qui peuvent être qualifiés
effectivement bénins et tout à fait dans
les règles de ce qui se pratique au sein
de l'Union européenne que malgré tout ça
fasse sur nos opinions publiques des
États membres
une forme justement de de
comment pourrais-je dire de crédibilité
qui se perd de de la part de nos
concitoyens de je dirais même parfois de
suspicion de d'action dirigée peut-être
dans avec des intentions qui ne sont pas
celles affichées donc pouvez-vous nous
dire en réalité comment tout cela peut
être expliqué aux concitoyens simplement
des États membres pour que justement
cette compréhension soit la plupart
faite et la plus transparente possible
pour nos populations je vous remercie
la question est très intéressante c'est
une question de confiance
confiance dans nos
institutions elles ne peuvent
fonctionner que s'il y a confiance dans
la part des concitoyens j'ai demandé aux
administrations européennes
de faire ce lien lorsqu'il y a un
manque de transparence s'il n'y a pas de
sanction alors il
faut comprendre que la confiance n'en
est que sapé les temps sont difficiles
les élections du Parlement européen
approchent alors j'aimerais vous donner
quelques exemples j'ai parlé du
pantouflage
il y a eu deux affaires ou une mauvaise
administration a été constatée
l'Autorité bancaire européenne tout
d'abord
la direction exécutive a été autorisée
par cette autorité
s'engager dans des activités de lobbying
et l'Autorité bancaire européenne
avait vu le jour après la crise
financière un objectif de cette autorité
était de rétablir la confiance des
concitoyens
vis-à-vis de du système réglementaire
donc
des questions de confiance ont été
remises sur la table
depuis les règles ont changé on nous
expliquait que les choses seraient fait
différemment puis pour le l'Agence
européenne de la défense la direction
exécutive a été autorisée
à travailler pour Airbus
il y a des contrats avec l'Union
européenne comme vous le savez
et donc les mêmes commentaires ont été
formulés
pour ce qui est des échanges de SMS
l'affaire vanderline et l'agence
on a fait les différentes on ne sait
toujours on a toujours aucune
information sur ces messages textuels il
y a donc un secret
et cela donne place un scepticisme un
neurocepticisme donc de confiance on
pose des questions
on se demande si la confiance est encore
légitime alors je l'ai dit à plusieurs
reprises
à l'époque la présence vanderline
a avec raison de faire ses efforts pour
que des vaccins soient disponibles
avec les personnes qui souffraient à des
personnes qui mouraient
c'est à juste titre qu'elle est allé à
la recherche de vaccins mais c'est une
question de transparence
particulière dans une société où vous
avez ces réseaux sociaux qui peuvent
faire monter le scepticisme nous
entendons souvent des responsables
d'administration d'administration
d'organes politiques
on les entend parler de confiance c'est
de montrer que leur travail est légitime
donc il faut être particulièrement
vigilant
même pour des affaires qui peuvent
paraître mineurs
puisque nous parlons là de la confiance
des concitoyens
merci
une question peut venir en plus en fait
dans le propos général que je vous ai
adressé c'est celui qui concerne le
sponsoring par les entreprises privées
de de pays qui ont peut-être une
administration moins moins pléthorique
donc de plus petit pays
où vous avez
voilà vous avez quelquefois on peut
avoir des surprises au moment des votes
ou au sein du conseil donc est-ce que
est-ce que vous percevez ça ou est-ce
que vous le ressentez
par le passé il y a eu divers intérêts
commerciaux en jeu puisque la présidence
peut-être lucrative
nous avons su des plaintes à ce sujet
il a été considéré qu'il y avait conflit
d'intérêt
et que les coûts de la présidence du
Conseil ne pouvaient pas être associé à
ces intérêts de privés
c'est pourquoi
nous avons élaboré des lignes
directrices
avant de demander à ce que c'est
pratique prennent fin
et par le résultat a été un peu parsemé
si je puis dire
la prochaine présidente qui est proche
et
il y aura encore sponsoring de la part
de certaines entreprises mais je reviens
à ce que je disais plutôt en tant que
médiatrice il faut faire preuve de
patience
on soulève ces questions
pose la question mais à l'ordre du jour
de discussion politique
et
peut-être que dans quelques années nous
pourrons voir cette pratique prendre
soin nous verrons d'autres alternatives
pour financer les présidents du conseil
donc les travaux sont en cours
et il est
facile de comprendre pourquoi les
concitoyens
verraient d'un mauvais œil cette
influence de la part d'entreprise privée
et il faut que l'on puisse garantir à
cette concitoyens que l'on protège les
intérêts juste encore deux points madame
la médiatrice d'abord la question que je
vous ai posée aussi dans mon propos
général sur ce que vous pensiez du plan
mezzola en 14 points par rapport au
Qatar gate la façon dont vous le dont
vous l'appréhendez est-ce que c'est un
plan
utile et comment comment il va se
déployer et puis un petit un deuxième
point aussi sur la question de la
transparence de Frontex il y a eu
énormément de polémiques énormément
d'articles qui ont été écrits la
gouvernance de frontext a été a été
remodelé ici même on a fait de gros
travaux pour essayer de comprendre à la
ce qui s'était passé mais aussi de
comprendre dans quel contexte tout ceci
était arrivé donc voilà si vous pouviez
répondre à ces deux questions aussi
merci
pour ce qui est du plan 14 points
l'été du Parlement européen ont été
impliqués le secrétaire général d'autres
instances et ce qui ressort
c'est une dilution
il y avait des attentes au départ la
panique au sortir du ce qu'on a
cathargate la présidente mensuel avec
ses inquiétudes sur la démocratie et
lorsque l'on parle d'attaque contre la
démocratie on va évidemment tout mettre
en œuvre pour faire la lumière et
apporter une réponse
mais
la politique entre en jeu et
on
observe un équilibre dans le Parlement
européen et
de façon générale la gauche les Verts
on privilégié des restrictions plus
sévères le centre droit moins donc tout
dépend des nombres des chiffres
il y a cet exemple je pourrais citer il
y avait cette proposition des parts de
période de réflexion de deux ans pour
les députés européens donc deux ans
après la fin du mandat
il faut mon sens que la proposition soit
raisonnable et finalement la période a
été fixée à 6 mois voilà un exemple
d'éléments qui ont été dilués
mais depuis le 14 gay
nombre concitoyens ordinaires si une
telle chose existe ont pris conscience
de l'importance de la déontologie de ce
qui fait une bonne agence théologique et
premier élément ils ont compris qu'il
faut que l'organe soit indépendant
décidé de se qui doit faire l'objet
d'une enquête ou non
et
il peut y avoir un pouvoir proactif on
n'est pas obligé d'attendre qu'une
plainte soit déposée
et au sein du Parlement vous avez un
organe qui se compose de sites députés
un organe de conseil pour la présidence
il faut qu'on leur demande d'enquêter
lorsque enquête il doit y avoir il y a
des libérations puis une recommandation
est formulée à la présidente
il y a un processus assez similaire dans
la Commission européenne donc les deux
organes ont des réticences à ce que soit
mis sur pied une agence indépendante
et beaucoup de concitoyens vont penser
que s'il n'y a pas indépendance
alors
ça ne va pas fonctionner l'organe reçoit
des ordres de telle ou telle institution
et c'est peut-être cette agence
indépendante aurait
privilégier nos concitoyens
alors encore une fois cette agence
intéresse titionnelle dont on a parlé
est très éloigné de ce qui était attendu
au départ
vous savez il y a encore un long chemin
parcourir du travail à fournir il y a
des pressions évidemment au vu de des
élections parlementaires qui approchent
députés ne veulent pas avoir ces
questions c'est polémiques en suspens
mais il semble y avoir un écart entre la
rhétorique au départ du la crise du
katergate ce qui se passe maintenant
pour ce qui est de front tech il y a eu
de nombreuses enquêtes de menées
vous faites référence peut-être un
trajet dit dans les eaux large de la
graisse 600 coups
600 réfugiés dans la mer
une situation tragique
et puis il y a les trafiquants qui sont
servent pour source de revenus et ce qui
m'a surprises lorsque je j'ai lu des
articles à ce sujet c'est qu'il n'y a
pas d'organes vont enquêter et qui soit
considéré comme indépendant
les Frontex
impliqué sur ces sujets là
les députés appellent maintenant à ce
que soit mis sur pied une agence
internationale pour enquêter et c'est
assez surprenant qu'à l'échelle
européenne il n'y ait pas d'organes
de la sorte en tant que médiatrice
européenne
mes pouvoirs sont limités évidemment
et donc nous voulons voir si comment
contribuer mais Frontex a fait l'objet
de critique dans le rapport de Lola
flovis européen de lutte anti fraude le
dernier qui a conduit à la démission de
membres de la direction puis il y a eu
des allégations
[Musique]
de refoulement
donc il y a
une nouvelle directrice donc l'attache
de l'agence de s'assurer que soit
respectée les libertés fondamentales
donc nous allons voir mais je crois que
beaucoup de personnes ont été surprises
par le fait que cela puisse se passer
ils ne sont pas y avoir la réponse que
l'on attendrait normalement d'une
administration d'une institution
européenne au vu des valeurs européennes
et au vu de
l'importance de cette tragédie
madame la médiatrice écoutez je vous
remercie de tous ces échanges en tout
cas ça stimule chez nous
probable travail dans les mois à venir
sur cette question
notamment sur les recommandations
propres Parlement européen et puisque
vous venez d'évoquer aussi sur un
Frontex et Liger l'idée d'une d'une
structure complètement indépendante
comme les la vôtres qui ne soient pas
dépendantes ni de la commission enfin
entre autres de la commission
puisque aujourd'hui
une dépendance
liée liée à la commission donc je pense
que cette piste peut-être peut-être
effectivement intéressantes
très bien écoutez je vous remercie
beaucoup d'avoir donné une heure de
votre temps pour notre commission bonne
journée et je sais que je vois que vous
suivez la dernière session du du
Parlement européen donc bon suivi et
bonne session merci